welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's she-hulk unveiled the
mcu's new hulk down attorney at law
jennifer walters tatiana maslany
rendered in a bulky verdigris that even
she seems a bit uncomfortable with the
cgi vfx and overall design seems to be
all anyone can focus on at the moment
which is crazy to me because how could
you think about anything other than an
mcu superhero carrying a bodybuilder off
to pound town well on one giant green
hand this is the first trailer footage
we're seeing and often marvel trailers
show us unfinished vfx that are vastly
improved upon when the content releases
marvel even spruces up the vfx between
theatrical release and blu-ray release
even sometimes between weeks while a
movie's still in theaters they've also
been caught quietly updating the vfx on
disney plus episodes after the initial
upload so even our perceptions of what
constitutes proper standards of disney
live action vfx is pretty hard to
measure but on the other giant green
hand these marvel disney plus series are
reported to have budgets of tens of
millions of dollars per episode and if
the effects were still being rendered
why not wait to release the trailer
until you had footage or even just one
big reveal shot that you can be proud of
and if hulk looks so good in this
footage why not the title character you
know all eyes are gonna be on folks i
spend a lot of my time here at new
rockstars analyzing visuals and vfx and
i come from it not from a technical
approach but from a narrative and a
character vector and i can't help but
laugh whenever i see people commenting
things like the cgi looks like [ __ ] and
that is a fact i'm an expert because
folks there is no objective scale of
good versus bad cgi it's far more
complex than that now disney of course
has no excuse they have access to
cutting-edge vfx technology and based
off of the billions they're raking in
they really should spare no expense but
with any title ever its vfx is really a
factor of two things creative priorities
and economic pressures because folks the
reason we saw a she-hulk trailer this
week is that disney had to drop this
trailer to excite advertisers at their
upfronts meanwhile the vfx artists who
are working on she-hulk have a task more
difficult than any other marvel disney
plus title yet so go easy on them this
isn't just creating a beautiful backdrop
of the tva or the beautiful riches of
konshu skull there is a reason why
marvel studios does not want to commit
to making a live-action hulk title and
removed hulk from the final act of
infinity war making a believable cool
hulk face is really really hard and with
that i agree that the imagery of
she-hulk in this trailer doesn't really
live up to what we expect from marvel
but here is the secret with vfx it is a
magic trick we know in our brains it is
not real but we suspend our disbelief
and we just go along with it if you look
hard enough you can find imperfections
in anything from a velociraptor in
jurassic park vanishing for a frame or
two in the t-rex's mouth to elsa's
ponytail magically clipping through her
arm during let it go it does not matter
unless as you are watching the full
movie in the theater or the full episode
on your tv it actively distracts you in
that moment from enjoying the narrative
beat now of course the tough sell with
she-hulk is her unusual appearance is
really the core hook of the series like
we are totally invited to scrutinize her
appearance the trailer even compliments
her ass your ass looks crazy right now
now you may have seen the criticism that
she-hulk in this trailer and other cgi
characters people have complained about
fall within what's called the uncanny
valley but what is that really the
uncanny valley was a term coined in 1970
by japanese robotics engineer masahiro
mori who observed that as robots became
more and more human-like they risk
crossing into a threshold in which their
emulation of human appearances and
mannerisms backfires as we suddenly see
them as psychologically unnerving and
suddenly they look like soulless flesh
puppets now animated films have had
mixed success with this over the years
pixar's had tremendous success deferring
to non-human characters and then loading
up those characters with deeply human
emotion meanwhile movies like the polar
express pushed human realism way too far
and slipped right in that valley the
first design of sonic valley cats valley
but the way successful cgi characters
have avoided the valley is by
reimagining their entire anatomical
structure gollum in the lord of the
rings films is a hideous goblin humanoid
but has a misshapen skull imbued with
highly expressive human features
enormous eyes with proportionally over
wide pupils and a tremendous attention
to detail into the facial skin so human
skin is semi-translucent it's made up of
several layers of epidermis covering
muscles all working in harmony covered
with hairs and indentations blemishes
various imperfections that our minds
perceive as realistic and light catches
all of these layers creating what's
called subsurface scattering now in the
avatar films the navi look pretty good
because of all the texturing the way the
various layers of their skin and the
hairs on their skin respond to light and
when we see them our brains don't say
hey that looks weird because they're
totally different skulls they only
vaguely evoke zoe saldana and sam
worthington now texturing is what marvel
vfx crews have gotten really really good
at the hairs and the grains on thanos
face the lines and the creases of smart
hulk's face thanos isn't just josh
brolin's face on a purple body smart
hulk is it is ruffalo's face on a green
body they have completely different
skulls underneath all that skin that
mannerisms that just evoke the way those
actors talk and it doesn't really matter
that they're ugly because they're meant
to be intimidating or comedic and herein
lies the challenge with she-hulk now
whether you're a marvel hero battling
off the sinister six or just fighting
off some sinister snacks it's hard to
find healthy snacks that taste great
well thankfully
is here to help toodaloo is a tasty
snack with functional benefits such as
supporting focus gut health energy and
skin so that you can be your best you
hot to trot is a spicy citrix mix smoke
show is bbq slow your roll as maple and
turning heads is chocolate flavored i'm
gonna try to slow your roll it's got a
sweet maple mix of sprouted nuts and
seeds chewy super fruits coconut rishi
ashwagandha mukunda i i don't know what
all these things are but it sounds good
let's try a bit
hmm
oh this is good
that was really good
oh it's so tasty i'm gonna do my
two-to-loo dance doo-da-loo
i like eating doodle so toodaloo is a
unique trail mix packed with helium
adaptogenic herbs like lion's mane and
ashwagandha that helps your body's
natural ability to relieve stress and
produce energy they are non-gmo
plant-based and grain-free i'm told
off-screen producer zach and tommy tried
the turning heads chocolate clusters and
devoured the entire bag before anyone
else could get a chance to try them
every order of their four tasty flavors
heals both you and the planet by
regenerating polluted farmland so you
feel great about what you are eating and
buying so go to my link at twodulu.com
new rockstars and use my code new
rockstars to get five dollars off your
first order each ridiculously tasty
flavor benefits your body in a different
way so choose your favorite flavor and
benefit from skin health digestion focus
relaxation thanks again toodaloo for
sponsoring this video she-hulk is a
multifaceted character in the pages of
marvel comics a deconstruction of the
rage monster trope and a satire of the
over-sexualization of female superheroes
she must be strong and hulk-like yet
beautiful and as an embodiment of sexual
liberation someone you could imagine
sleeping with a normal human now bruce
banner hulk in this trailer looks as
great as ever and that's because the vfx
team could just use the same character
design and templates that were already
created for avengers in-game but with
she-hulk they are designing this
character from scratch from the bones up
and unlike hulk and unlike thanos she
cannot be monstrous and caveman-like she
must still be attractive and retain the
easy on the eyes dimensions of tatiana
maslany's natural face the result is
that she-hulk in this early footage
often just looks like maslany's face is
digitally painted green and mapped into
the middle of a huge mane of hair it
actually may remind you of will smith as
genie in the 2019 aladdin which was
another instance where those filmmakers
felt they needed to keep the precise
contours of the actor's face now i don't
know if it's fair to say maslany
she-hulk falls into the uncanny valley
because i think the proportions of her
face regardless of the body it's on
isn't that freakish to look at like i
certainly don't think she-hulk needs a
sonic level redesign really the main
issue that they're still clearly working
on is the texturing of she-hulk's skin
and how it responds to light like notice
how hulk's skin looks bumpy and almost
yellow brown in natural light but
she-hulk's skin is almost always bright
lime green just really one color tone
and when you look at it closely her skin
really lacks detail causing it to at
this stage look unnaturally smooth and
rubbery especially when it moves and
shifts under the light now it doesn't
help that disney uploads these trailers
to youtube super compressed as is the
compression on disney plus uploads but
honestly that might be to gloss over
some of these rough edges really it's
only distracting in character close-ups
like the slightly unnatural movement
when she straightens up while looking at
her phone and when she flirts with her
date this is the best date i've had in a
while oh should we split some fries
let's get those to go
now while mislani's voice is great there
the movement of her eyebrow is a [ __ ]
and smirk of her lips they're just stiff
and restrained probably not the same
expression maslany actually made under
the mocap the expressions have almost no
effect on the surrounding skin and as a
result we lose some of that flirtation
now again all of this is still being
rendered and i think this scrutiny is
completely overblown like all magic
tricks it's about the overall experience
and i think the tone in the world and
the relationships will ultimately be
what we most enjoy from this series and
i think the best example of why we
should be optimistic about this is the
final shot of the trailer when she
carries her date off to the bedroom it
doesn't really matter how good
she-hulk's texturing looks here because
it's all about the goofy visual gag it's
a huge dude completely smitten with
being cradled she-hulk doesn't even
struggle with the weight and that's
what's fun about it and honestly i do
not know how they pulled off this shot
like i assume they suspended this actor
with wires but his foot knocks into the
lamp and that lamp light shifts on the
furniture and on his feet that light
shifting looking pretty practical and
something is clutching his back to
crease his shirt like that so was it
maslany on stilts wearing a mocap suit
with one of those character face
popsicles over her head for the eye line
holding this guy but assisted with wires
or was she actually on a green screen
set here holding someone smaller or
something smaller and then they synced
it with a shot of an empty practical set
where they move the lamp i mean it's
just fun to think about all these
permutations again it's a magic trick
and that is how good vfx should be you
don't really know what the machinery is
and that's why despite the unfinished
vfx elsewhere in this footage i still
leave this trailer smiling and excited
for the series good vfx is all about the
narrative the character the moment and
the way the vfx interacts with the
practical environment so she-hulk is
gonna give us more moments like this i
think i'm gonna love this show follow me
on instagram twitter at eavos following
the rockstar subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you